[Music]
[Music]
hello and good morning everyone how's it
going it's going good I'm waking up I've
had my coffee oh man I didn't have any
coffee but it's fine because we're gonna
have some potassium today ok ha ha
yeah guys are playing my friend Pedro on
the Nintendo switch and it's been pretty
fun you know I played a little bit of it
so we're gonna start fresh from the
beginning for you guys and yeah it is
available now so if you're interested in
playing it make sure you get it cuz I
definitely think it's worth it's pretty
fun I was telling uh John Lee earlier I
feel like it's like Shadow Complex and
Deadpool I had a baby and it would be
something like this so I'm pretty
excited with a hotline Miami thrown in
yeah sorry we're just getting ready to
ski no let's do it and we are here at
the scene that Xfinity smart-home which
you can see behind us we have this
wallpaper TV and it's called wallpaper
because it is literally just so thin
it's insane it's thinner than my cell
phone every time I see it oh ok hey hey
hi wake up let's see crime wants to know
if I can turn off slow mode in the chat
crime I'll figure that out for you
I don't know who turned that on I assume
that was left on from like III is why
rise and shine sleepyhead
alright so here we are and we're
confused and we have a talking banana so
Pedro's the banana yes okay Pedro is our
friend our banana friend but the word
friend yeah but it went fine am I really
your friend okay
all right so you know there you know
look around we jump and aim ding the
door is locked its classic video game
Naha look okay so we do have wall jumps
which are fun and Paige was very
encouraging I mean this feels very
necessary because it's right now just
teaching you how to play the game but I
was watching you play like you know
later levels and it's just so bananas
[Laughter]
yes indeed how does it feel on the
switch controller by the way um I
actually don't mind it I'm using it with
you know the little adapter but when I
was playing earlier like on the solution
was actually connected to the little
screen it feels friggin okay because
this this feels like the game I'd maybe
want to play with like a mouse and
keyboard person usually because there's
definitely a lot of different like
things you can do and for like a few
moments late in the later stages I did
find myself kind of like clawing the
controller and like oh yeah having a
press more than it looked like there was
a lot of different things you had to
manage at once mm-hmm a lot of times I'd
be like oh yeah I have this move and oh
yeah that Oh shucks
let's snitch to the butcher oh dang it's
all a facade
the meat is mainly rats pigeons or
whatever person they didn't like oh boy
hey boss
[Laughter]
oh I like his apron this is nice to meet
you Oh Martin although that also was
like he does indeed murder people yeah
exactly
useless slackers sigh alright he's
coming this way you have to take him out
says Pedro right he told us to the
banana told us to do it and then he's
like well I guess you have to kill them
all now so it's those damn this music is
nice I like this music a lot it is
pretty good
yeah and definitely as we go on it gets
just so crazy but so hilarious at the
same Specter yeah this is a dodge move
which is also pretty cheap
Pedro such a good friend
yeah he's really supportive helping you
out whoa okay oh he's got a banana bed
that's cute yeah so focus definitely
comes in handy later on for sure
boom nailed it shoot this priceless vase
this banana is too much okay yeah so run
jump do a spin break the game and almost
stuck the landing oh this is really
important in something like I'm still
working on C ideas so you can aim oops
no a good aim and then you hold down
your left trigger in the neighborhood
shoe all around town you're a mean but
kicking machine alright so thanks for
the tip Pedro and now we shall implement
into action slow mode aim split shot
flip everything at once make it happen
we did it that might have been the end
of the first stage and that's just
interests this tutorial yeah because I
will say I have like rarely ever ranked
higher than like the lowest rank every
time so we'll try to aim better I mean
this seems like the kind of game where
you would play it and then immediately
want to replay it and like yeah it
matter and do like cool trick montages
oh yeah I'm ready full health I don't
need it I think every time we've like
seen this game I like packs or something
we're always like ask the dev to like
playing for us because we're like you
know how to play this game and you yeah
look really cool I've never touched this
before
yeah technology in a nutshell he was
like these turrets they're so easy to
install you just do this this and then
they got murdered cry monster know if
the room light changes to what's on
screen no I think the lights are just
sad we dub that TV behind us that is
playing what we are currently playing
which is pretty cool yeah I like that a
lot actually
oops it's also very acrobatic I'm always
jumping off the wrong wall is this only
for switch no I think it's for
everything right um well switch in PC
for sure I know for a fact yeah check
that you can hear that yeah
clicky clicky oh no it's yeah it's
switch and PC but that's it I don't
think it's on a ps4 or Xbox all right
well there you go yeah playing on PC are
played on your switch it's running at
60fps on switch looks like it is I
couldn't even make it move of an exact
frame rate but it seems to be running
pretty smooth yeah I will see you like
games like this is a little harder to
tell then like maybe a fighting game or
something
miss tamesha says hi hello thanks for
joining us welcome back
nice to see you again oh yeah kicking
that's actually really funny dear I love
that because you are just kicking them
in the foot and then they decide yeah
it's a powerful kick Oh yep oh yeah
there you go
oh yeah
purple blood in the chat so they're from
India Wow I'm always amazed that the
people in the chat from like different
regions like some people are like I'm
from the Middle East I'm watching I'm
like oh that's so cool
I love that thank ya and thanks for
tuning in
like you could be doing anything with
your date I know and you're here I
always wonder what time it is there to
write it was like I'm so bad at that
yeah I'm just like honestly like the
middle of the night they're here you
know yeah that's cool though sometimes
people are like I'm in class I'm like
hey you do you I feel like I shouldn't
condone that but I don't know I feel
like I would have done the same I mean
the fastest way Toto go out of town is
through the restaurant let's do it do
all these guys no big deal I have purple
blood says it's uh 11:40 where they are
Wow woah that's a full 12-hour
difference
did you just fire me the guys what yeah
I think so yeah like some of the enemy
is if the if you're like making ruckus
above them oh they like little wines or
they'll have like shoes and they're like
one of the guys would be like did you
just fart I thought you were putting me
on blast
Wow geez gotta go get a bonus if you
kill everybody
oh yeah of course yes yeah I gotta do
that Oh date oh I'm supposed to go up
here catch oh I could have killed him
without going that way
it's fine things like cool little
puzzles and Seth you nothing too crazy
crime says I got admit Persia it was me
boom come on yes so far I've done better
on these levels I got nothing but C
ratings last time so we're getting
better improvement mmm indeed review was
coming soon outta still so I don't know
who is reviewing it but I already have a
review coming for this game
hey I am feeling this music yeah it's
good
scrumptious bees for bananas so what is
a and C stand for what does he was like
it was like come on
careless careless something like that
come on careless and something else
though coconut coconut yes
it's similar to marking the ninja
mark of the ninja is more of a spell
Thames this is sort of the opposite of
that in that sense
oh no oh no it's okay the Dodge is so
good everybody think I missed some
people need to go back I don't know I
think I think I'll get back there oh you
could flip tables Oh which is also great
hey buddy
how much is this game who do you know
how much I do not well on Steam right
now it is 20 bucks but it's currently
15% off or the next week or two
so 17 you wanna buy it on a lease that's
not even worth splitting bucks know that
Hales
snap here because I'm doing the cool
stuff last time I was just like oh my
god
oh and it shows you like your play of
the game code on code at the end like
your best moment we all know how play
the games go can I even be really cool
or like really embarrassing it was like
really that was right that was the play
how many times have you gotten like I
play the game in overwatch or you've
seen one where it's just a Torbjorn
standing there okay
turrets killing them pretty old yeah
cool I haven't seen him before
Wow his bodies there's Swizzy way too
many times I'm like oh man I'm not gonna
make this job
so the architecture in these buildings
bizarre like in real life why would they
just be like a door that goes to like
two fences that's it you can like dodge
spin kick Oh actually yeah I have to
have the machine guns never
amazing the shotgun still has to be my
favorite though oh I'm gonna get this
bigger I'll kill ya nice oh that one
wool yep yep keep going keep going all
the way oh yeah there you go
[Laughter]
I'm looking forward to playing this but
I think even more so I'm looking forward
to watching videos on YouTube of people
like Hannah these crazy runs it's like
no damage all headshots like
oh you can shoot and kick at the same
time you know that changes things
I'll be here oh I hate you Barry there
we go
no stuck on barrel okay I've got supreme
dodging skills hey cut it out old man
it's a lot of damage at the end there
yes I barely got it but it wasn't a see
and our play of the game was our barrel
our watch that was definitely the best
part yeah yeah all crime is saying there
already is a video on GameSpot of
someone doing an s-rank run so I guess
I'll go hey we do get stuff so much good
stuff that we even sometimes I'm also
playing on normal so I think that
automatically like bans me from ever
getting a string from anything how do
you think so it actually is determined
by there is like another like at the end
when it counts all your bonuses there's
one slot for difficulty bonus and it's
like always empty
growing 3d perspective I am reading your
chats right now
oh yeah bear I'll kill scoopers sub game
swap people sub thanks for joining us
welcome happy thursday is it's already
Thursday I know right I took one of my
my III days off that we get yesterday in
the middle of the week it's like you
come back and it's already Thursday
really oh this is great exactly feeling
and refresh I originally wasn't
convinced I was like oh I don't want to
take like Wednesday off cuz then I have
to like come back and work no like I
don't wanna do that it's kind of true
but then our co-worker Michael Hine was
oh man now oh and that's a pretty
awesome-looking
yeah oh yeah good job about my coworker
Michael I was saying like no man if you
take off Wednesday it's like a mini like
second you know weekend in the middle
I'm like that's a good point so it was
pretty good it's pretty great crime
iceberg borne beta is tomorrow we are
gonna do something with that I don't
forget to do a stream because tomorrow
we're actually doing Crash Team Racing
oh yeah for community Fridays that's
gonna be very exciting so we actually
got we're gonna get Nick Sherman
yeah really good who is really really
good at that game he has any time you've
seen a gameplay of us that we've put up
that's like really good that is most
likely Nick Sherman fine because he is
really good at Crash Team Racing
what's the story of this game a banana
named Pedro asks you to murder people is
what I'm getting out of it accurate aaaa
didn't you just see the game tell me go
inside I'm bleeding
Lord ghosts in gaming I don't think the
game is coming out on ps4 at least not
right now I'm looking up it's only
available on switch and PC maybe
eventually it'll come to ps4 and Xbox
but right now it's just these two
platforms oh boy I'll bent on the chat
Punjab somehow yeah Beryl so aggressive
a revolver bullet been is a philanthropy
in the chat he is one of our lovely
video boys you can see he'll he's
actually on a fair amount of streams as
well I mean him to a community Friday
show which will be on tomorrow tomorrow
Friday and we're gonna be playing Crash
Team Racing I'm excited for that game I
like crash a lot I've never played
the racing kart racing across town yeah
neither have I actually it's always been
like Mario Kart or like cartoon our days
he forgot how many occurrences there
were back in the day there was like a
period where everyone had a kart racer
yeah that was the thing and it was fun
too
I feel like those games aren't easy we
used to like keep your characters and
stuff yeah cool you can kind of cool
guest characters in there yes there for
the most part simple you know easy to
pick up
scoopers yes for playing this on the
switch yeah I actually like this thing I
don't know why I like I don't know even
when I play - oh dang my record was real
bad could do better
you right you're right Paige roading
judging me hey I like that the button
the d-pad they're like all buttons
instead of like an actually been right
it definitely works better for some
games but then there's other times where
I'm like oh I would love like a nice
d-pad fine
chants tables
I'm your way
it's like every stage they add something
else that's just like equally satisfying
yeah I mean I was watching you play the
second chapter I guess we need to call
it and like even like all the way up
until the end they were alike they kept
adding new mechanics of new things oh
yeah
it's so cool it's so great and have you
seen the trailer he does in the trailer
also so it's like pretty cool I'm trying
to like oh he's picked that in his face
yes I know if a lasers don't want to set
off the go up
that thing hey ya know oh nice
daddy here I will kick you alright
come on come on
so claw oh but it was a fragment boom I
killed him women and then I ricocheted
and killed the other guys that's
definitely deserves to be here that was
good
it's kind of cool that they can
determine that cuz I thought the run
ride just like murdered like ten people
in a row I was like that might be it
no it's the style point it's all about
the style oh yeah then is right the
shotgun is amazing we'll get to that
this guy Mitch he's a real piece of work
[Music]
oh yeah motorcycle time
they kind of add something different to
like a different element every time so
it's like this is the motorcycle one and
then there's like a couple of other
different ways to play towards the end
cool this is cool
[Music]
I actually want to save that for the
boss
they gave me a mo
[Music]
whoa
whole shindig going on over here we're
in the Holland Tunnel uh-oh
I am look at streets going here
come on there we go No
and it does he just slow-mo backflip his
way through this whole part oh yeah
there you go
[Music]
it's so like action-movie doubt it's
great I'm telling you dead bull and
shadow conflicts all right Mitch
oh man I'm about to run out of ammo
[Music]
the background I think it's just actual
video footage somebody recorded like
them driving your goon out of here Mitch
whoa
nope okay who I was worried for a second
you need to lay low for a while
here things Ben was saying the original
version of this game actually came out
before Deadpool or Shadow Complex family
oh yeah
did the original version of this game
come out Shadow Complex came out a while
ago yeah Shadow Complex pre-owned ooh
yes very silky smooth yeah
Oh apparently used to be a flash game on
Miniclip Wow yeah we were just like you
mount bananaphone which was also pretty
old like new groans video those flash
games and flash videos man like they
have all those real-life escape games
now but people forget that started as
like a total flash game escape the room
find little clues yeah it's uh it's
crazy how many like I feel like game
mechanics now I like games starting
those flash games or like inspired by
them like yeah I mean angry angry birds
used to be like a flash game that you'd
play basically super meat boy I think
was a flash game at one point that
documentary is you indie game the movie
that's very good
what is going on over here having a
Christmas Brady and we just got a bounce
he put on her in and the guy that just
said hey nice mask he was like wait I
just saw him well hot dang ain't that
lucky I like that they're all in
sweaters I know other laying low not
that low
alrighty then hop the zipline out of
here oh yeah trials trials used to be a
flash game trials
that's the with the motorcycle where
you're like oh yeah
have to kind of like maneuver in those
games are really fun a lot of those
games were really like tormenting too
because it was like they were so hard
yeah like you have to make the guy walk
by using like oh yeah like why is this
so hard when does this come out again I
think it's not today he said right yes
whoa okay cool yeah you can play it out
so now we've got levers and whatnot we
could shoot those bad boys so starts
getting really fun the way they want you
to like figure out how to get through
things and everything's kind of like a
mini puck he got that shot off that is
do Hankey if I've ever seen it
always forget to kick it's the coolest
thing and I always forget to do it hey
see I tried to get this earlier and I
messed up but my health was full this
time so oh he fell down I was like did I
just kill him my landings not even
really good hey is there a difficulty in
selection yes you said you're playing on
normal right now indeed is there just
one difficulty above normal or there are
a couple I think there's a couple okay
ben says he used to play trials instead
of doing schoolwork yeah that was the
big thing is uh you know you go to the
computer lab to work on your your paper
or whatever and then you just end up
playing flash games you had to find the
sites that your school hadn't banned
yeah exactly
yeah guy new grounds is off but they
haven't found out about final black
sheep yet so I'm one of that one you
bombs were all this on there for a
really long time before they banned that
yeah a surprisingly long time at my
school house week Wow house new grounds
Fanny bombs
you know surprisingly Nickelodeon comm
had some really fun oh they did yeah
Nickelodeon lego.com had a couple of fun
ones I remember oh and what was it
Kellogg or something the one that had
all of the like cereals that like Tonio
tiger and all yeah they have some cool
games too you know you know I had a
really good one to Bisco had a had a
mini-golf one and each like mini golf
course we based after a different like
Nabisco cake cool I remember really
really liking that one I like used to
play it out all the time Vince's new
feature idea top flash games you used to
play instead of paying attention in
class
our man let's get a I'll get my a
Spinelli on it
they were great there was this one
spongebob the flash game where you went
and literally like flip burgers and you
place orders and you filled out the
orders you meet all the Krabby Patties
and I just thought that was the coolest
game ever I played all the time and you
diner - kind of game yeah yeah yeah
played this other like mobile version of
diner - but it was like a sushi
restaurant and then you could like
upgrade and decorate your restaurant
Lord I'm such a sucker for games like I
- I really like games like that
the politicians didn't agree on which
fine type used a logo so the whole
project got abandoned sounds is another
reason I really like overcooked it's
because it's a different kind of game
but it has that same like you're
managing a restaurant kind of feel to it
and I'm I love Vince his best version of
Diner Dash is the Cadbury mini game in
Yakuza bring it back - yeah cos abend
gotta find a way to mention it the the
embargo lifted on judgment I not sure
part reviews up yet but if not pretty
soon and I would imagine I've been
playing that game for the last couple
weeks and I like it a whole lot it looks
really good it's really fun anyways
hilarious and everyone I was like Tyger
Tyger Tyger Dojima others are pretty
there's character in Yakuza called dye
goes oh oh no I was thinking about
judgment oh yeah is he okay well there's
like a character a looks like it oh
really
that's nice that was like everyone's
little joke really
oh yeah I did that like this
so we want to there then we're gonna go
up there we go
oh yeah yes yes yes oh so great that is
excellent nice
keepers
oh gosh
while I spin while I hang from the
and jump
oh geez oh geez oh geez
ah don't worry so like me I was just
talking about how I'm not exactly good
at platformer games like make me play a
Mario game that's probably not gonna be
the best game please representing I
always get scared I'm either gonna miss
the platform so I'm like moving back and
forth too much I don't just trust that
like you're gonna land on it it's gonna
be fine
I'm mad I died right there at the end Oh
- oh I probably would have at least had
to be so disappointing I think we're
getting close to a boss battle though so
oh wow really already
oh yeah this is where the really thumbs
yes yes it's so cheap they can't do
anything about that
we were also wondering like who who did
this to put do installed beauty what is
the purpose of them why why do you need
those there other Ventris I want to
conveniently use to ricochet bullet
exactly so well please tbz King No
Pedro's not on xbox unfortunately it
looks like it's just on switch and PC
right now
I can like feel the controller yeah all
the action how I'm dying though I was
trying to do something cool and it
didn't work out cuz now I'm dying I was
trying to split shot the both the
ricochets oh that B and now Paige was
like you know dodge those bullets once
in a while oh there we go oh wow wow wow
wow I believe in you you got these
stellar dodges get that guy ricochet
yeah okay
oh yeah this is Otto up stop it
get it out I wanted to do the cool thing
distracting me okay
but I'm gonna make sure I have this one
she's little satisfied
oh yeah Wow
get close they're so chilled the banana
so the banana is Pedro is that your
friend Pedro said banana that talks to
you and tells you to people yes play the
game is the best it's so satisfying
oh what's the play of the game the yes
thanks Pedro oh yeah the shotty shotgun
now I'm already dying though you kick
their body parts is now that we can make
them like explode pretty much hey I know
dang it it hurts
yeah cuz they're using the shotty to
and help y'all there we go
shadi is so broken no Sparta he wants to
know is worth playing this game I would
say yes I haven't even played it myself
but just watching you play it I
definitely am gonna check this out yep
there you go and watch him die in
slow-mo yeah but he got me first no my
nose as bonus
oh they blinked
unfortunately to go so I'm just
rappelling down a wire with a shotgun
can't see me
Ben says he's usually in slo-mo 80% of
the time seems like a good way to play
it
Alex it is so yeah it's it's kind of a
linear like you go through each level
and they're kind of scripted out where
you're solving these just combat puzzles
may be a good way to put it yeah sorts
of games length we've been playing for
about an hour
right LLC and we're I'm not sure how far
into this we're almost at the end of
like the second chapter yeah which i
think is gonna be almost half no like a
little lesson hello that's a little
lesson halfway might make it to your
pages where else yes where we stop do we
want to show that I know it's like what
should we do if we make it there
beforehand I mean we don't an hour
that's pretty good it's a shorter game
so I'm okay not doing a full I want to
have stream because I don't want to
spoil yeah and for people cuz it does
get pretty crazy and never like
definitely thinking about it we were
like it's kind of spoilery yeah I don't
want to run skateboards that obvious
she's awesome
you can do some this seems like really
tough but like I feel like if you get
the get a handle on it you do something
okay nice yes I was like oh no I'm just
trying to do that ready the the kick
bottom Oh see we can land right on it oh
oh oh no dang it
so you can basically kick the skateboard
into them however I've failed to do that
I didn't I'm really
oh my gosh that's not open on that side
[Laughter]
no got health up there and just make it
there we go
[Music]
so great
[Music]
last thing you could have kicked the
gasoline can up in the air oh you're
right you're right I was like I don't
want them to shoot it trying to shoot me
but that would have been way cooler more
style points okay dang it
[Music]
Oh healthy I need that quick I think
you're getting real close I'm stuck as a
skateboard like hey yeah yeah this is it
[Laughter]
this is really hard
come on yes yes see the no death bonus
it kept me out of the C rating hey this
is the boss this is I think so I'm
pretty sure we might have to chase him
oh no vitreous
it always gets to the end of the loading
screen and I'm like did it freeze but
now it is here gentle would you be a
bounty hunter every came with tinsel hmm
you get done so hard to come by
well maybe although I got done till
right now and I don't have to kill
people absolutely I'd be really bad at
being a bounty on her
nice yeah okay try and kick those out
yeah all almost Wow Wow
no I miss definitely would have gave me
massive style points
dang what oh oh oh oh hey
like these random fences he's poor
these poor bounty hunters they were just
set up for failure step up that iam
buddy AI on normal difficulty all my
friends and I should well so it's almost
2 a.m. where they are oh not there they
have to head out because it's less late
hey I don't blame you thanks for
watching though that's awesome I think I
actually just kicked them I tried to
kick this caper again
oh I could use a stapler this hole right
I forgot it's way cooler like that oh
there we go
No I had a rhythm going and I and then I
went all the way back okay Mary yeah
there we go
oh the shoddy damage beautiful even the
game said so alright that no death bonus
be kept me alive see I tried to I
decided to kick in with it but I just
ended up kicking him and the skin is a
ranking system it's pretty brutal you're
like doing really good it's just like
barely scraping by pains a lot of time
I'm like what do you want from us you
want me to maybe I'm not using enough
focus not enough style
oh maybe oh crap I forgot about that
oh man I'm not supposed to let them
sound the alarm
yeah lobby worst thing you have to
master the focus for it cat oh my
goodness I'm already dying
if I had to keep these mofos away from
that thing
hey don't you run
nice
come on go on take it that guy's
ricochet yeah okay cool
now now you you stop it
you okay
although the shaadi is pretty effective
against the terrorists yeah short work
of it plants through this earlier how
long as I don't want to burn through it
I mean again we Justin we played about
an hour yeah so far we're a little less
than half the lesson halfway so I'd
imagine it's probably two two and a half
hours depending on how good you are but
it definitely seems like the kind of
game you want to replay a couple times
nice
[Music]
now
all right that's the end and then the
boss I think no no alarms bonus there is
a bonus for that dang it I tried
thank ya so cool you see it back then
can see them oh yeah
Xfinity smart home all right Denny we
ran all through your smart home just to
find you
oh my gosh Danny
nice
[Laughter]
they're pretty good it saves points
though yeah very forgiving keep the pace
going you know
can I just stay on the skateboard what
is it
jump in order to stay on it we played
off of a ramp or something
dingus I'm like in the momentum of like
oh oh crap all right here we go
she
Hey
come on Denny
yeah
[ __ ]
okay good yeah okay no oh she's out help
my butt out okay
reload oh jeez oh are you so close
[Music]
oh okay yeah the reload right there come
on man just leave me alone
never got it Pedro quickly jump after
him
yo man yeah
coconut status for sure that one's tough
no one has talked so I think we got one
more level here and then yeah might be a
good place to call it yeah I think so
too the next level is like almost too
fun and interesting yeah I want to spoil
it
this is also very good now yes fun
dang it already
oh the frying pan yeah oh I'm dying okay
wait wait stop don't shoot I just
deliver the messages man oh it's always
the system huh if I had a bigger bread
vector of the Internet
yeah she's the director of the Internet
and Mitch was her dad it's all making
sense wait a second
aren't you is that you will never know
speaking of which grounds coming up for
the water level completed and we got
massive amounts of points that you got
your restaurant oh yeah oh man I'm
surprised it wasn't the the frying pan
clip cuz that was like amazing all right
but yeah so we're gonna call it right
are we are this is for y'all's sake not
ours I don't want to be spoilers exactly
we already played through two whole
chapters by the way which was pretty fun
so definitely yeah it seems like the
kind of game even if you wash it though
I mean you gotta play yourself yeah
exactly like once you start learning the
controls it's really smooth it starts to
become more like intuitive the way you
have to like shoot and fight and like
Wendy used to focus and when to go for
like all the creative tools and stuff
like that so I would highly recommend
playing this game I had a lot of fun
playing it and it didn't really take
long at all for me to like pick it up
and you know feel like I was capable so
that's that's bonus points for me
personally also like games that are like
really really hard to play right off the
jump that have like a steep learning
curve it like it's harder to get into it
sooner that way so yeah it seems like
the kind of game where no matter what
you feel you feel cool and it's all
about feeling more
cool exactly so yeah thanks for joining
us today you guys at the scene at
Xfinity smart home make sure you tune in
every day at 11 a.m. every weekday met
11 a.m. for gamespot live tomorrow
community Fridays oh yeah playing crash
bandicoot oh yes I'm crash team racing
so that's gonna be really fun and on
Monday we'll be back here at the smart
home playing some Street Fighter 5 with
eg ricky ortiz so i'm very excited about
that i'm so make sure you guys are
tuning in and we'll catch you guys
tomorrow bye
you